what's going on in your life right now
this is a long story i you know
there's an ongoing struggle with ice
cream um
i don't understand what do you mean i
struggle with ice cream look i don't
know like who
sounds like you're talking about a
rapper yeah i'm having a struggle with
ice cream it's so sad because he's such
a friendly wrapper
it really is so what do you mean by this
you have to explain this what do you
have a struggle with ice cream look i
don't know
as a grown up whether ice cream's a good
thing
it seems to me that for you know ice
cream is for two things for adult shame
and fun for children
right that that's the only way ice cream
functions for me let me try to explain
it's a long thing
but i will try to fill it in for you
okay i like i don't
i'm 50 i can't be eating ice cream every
day
i would like to who wouldn't but um
but i have this ongoing problem where
like i'll get home like
i'll be sitting at home it's like 10 30
at night i've made it through the day
okay right yeah and i'm like i could go
to sleep now
but then some part of me is like no man
you should go out and get ice cream now
and so i try to negotiate with that part
of my brain i'm like that's not a good
idea we're about to go to bed and it
goes shut up stupid
you want ice cream and then i look at my
watch and like the supermarket near me
is open to 11.
i'm gonna go down there and stand before
that glorious freezer
and just look at ice creams for a few
minutes sure
and i'm like then i'm thinking like i'm
just gonna get a pint because there's
one there's like two servings in a pint
wrong they know that there's not two
servings in a pint
that pint is not that's for nothing but
shame and just eating it all
right you can't you can't eat half the
pint and put it
that is the point i'm making conan yes
all right
so here's what happens i appreciate you
reiterating it
here's what happens so i go
and i stand before the freezer and i you
know i look at the the array of ben and
jerry's flavors that are just different
versions of there's way too much in
this ice cream
you know you know and funny lettering
you know which version do i need so then
you grab that i'm like i'm just getting
a pint but then you have that moment
like i'm going to need
i'm going to need to cut it with vanilla
so i got
right so you got to get the vanilla cut
yeah right so now
now i didn't even want ice cream right
now i'm going home with two pints
right so then the drama begins the
struggle so i get home and i'm like just
gonna have a bowl a little bowl
take the ice cream scoop it out of the
pint put it in the bowl
a couple a couple hits of vanilla take
the edge off
you know no one says hits of vanilla
they just don't well no one's apparently
no one's taking hits of other things
so i'm very
hit oriented yes i understand back in
the day i understood
so there we go so i got the bowl sit
down like a human adult
and nicely eat my ice cream and i take
the ball put it in the sink
put the spoon in the sink good i'm done
i'll go sit on the couch for a minute
so i sit on the couch within three
minutes i'm like oh no
i'm gonna i need i'm gonna eat some more
of that
[Laughter]
so then you go back and now the bowl's
not necessary but the spoon is necessary
because
now you're in warfare with the ice cream
now it's not a fun thing it's like
you know like so like like so you don't
even take it to the couch i'm over the
freezer i'm just like
like fast fast but not angry not angry
yet
so that's the second time so i'm like
alright i'm done and then i throw the
spoon
in the sink and go sit down i should be
going to bed but now i'm gonna i'm gonna
play with the
the situation a little longer so then
the third time it's a little it's a
little ridiculous because i'm like
i turn the tv off and i'm like damn it
back to the freezer and then like i take
the spoon now i'm angry i'm like you
know screw this you know
i'm eating it right and i leave like two
spoonfuls and you're like that's a
victory i didn't eat the whole thing
right so i put the two spoonfuls back
in the freezer get in bed i'm in bed
lights are off i'm i'm in my boxers
partially naked is what i'm saying and
and then i'm laying in bed i'm like i
did good you know there's still some ice
cream left
and then that voice is like oh you're
stupid
go eat the rest of it so then i go out
there in my boxers i eat the rest and i
go like you're an
idiot why'd you do that you could have
been sleeping
and then i go and to reward myself for
shame and ice cream i masturbate
okay there's no
there's no way to follow
a battle with ice cream other than
masturbating you know
because like either you're going to feel
good you're just going to amplify your
shame
right and i just love the nod andy's
giving you now oh yeah
yeah tell it brother
tell it
the biggest problem as andy knows with
this system is i've still got about a
half a pint of vanilla in there
yeah that i used to cut the other stuff
with right so now i got to go get
another pint of too much in this
ice cream
to finish the video go and get more of
the ben and jerry's to finish up the
vanilla
not after masturbating but the next day
okay
i didn't want to know the order things
happened at least i'm not masturbating
in front of the freezer
you know what hey
[Applause]
that would actually be a healthier
option but i might get arrested i
believe my question was
how you doing i believe that was my
question
is that it yeah and now you're in front
of the freezer